and finally new rule now that Jeb Bush
and Ted Cruz have both admitted to
smoking weed as teenagers I must admit
that as a teen I once tried on a pair of
khakis it was a mistake I didn't like
the way it made me feel and I never did
again yeah
take it from me kids khakis are a bad
scene man now I bring this up because I
think it is time to declare that the
media ritual of asking presidential
candidates if they ever smoke pot can be
put to rest because the answer is always
yes and nobody cares everyone from Bill
Clinton everyone from Bill Clinton to
Newt Gingrich Al Gore to Rick Santorum
John Kerry to Sarah Palin they have all
fessed up come on when even dead grows
cops do it that one surprised me I must
be here I thought who would get high
with Teddy Walker drunk enough me Ted
spokesman said when senator Cruz was a
teenager he foolishly experimented with
marijuana it was a mistake and he's
never tried it since no please the
mistake was stopping now of course I
don't have a problem with any of this
because when I was younger I also smoked
and when I say when I was younger I mean
just before the show
no no the problem I have is that this is
the standard answer we get from all
these guys nowadays some form of hey
when I was young and stupid I was young
and stupid is no big deal
which is great except that's not a
defense that's really available for most
of the 700,000 Americans who get
arrested every year so so if we're going
to keep doing that we should at least be
honest with our kids and tell them the
truth about drug laws in this country
kids if you're gonna experiment make
absolutely certain that beforehand your
parents are white and well-connected
it's a good safety tip
when Jeb Bush was at prep school he was
apparently not just a pothead but a
dealer but he dismisses that by saying
back then I was a cynical little turd at
a cynical school okay but then when you
became a governor of the state you
insisted on mandatory sentences for drug
crimes and a policy of jail only no
treatment for drug users except when it
was your daughter when you made an
exception wow that sounds like something
a cynical turd would do
you know that Jeb's father the first
President Bush was the last president
who didn't smoke pot you can see the
progression from Clinton copping to it
but still needing to say he didn't
inhale to george w bush not denying it
just saying he wouldn't answer to obama
who said yeah I smoke weed I smoked a
lot of it and I look cool doing it yeah
but don't all these guys Clinton Jeb w
Obama don't they all owe a debt to the
40,000 unlucky Americans currently in
jail for the exact same crime
in David Axelrod's new book he confirms
that Obama actually was always for gay
marriage he just couldn't say it for a
long time because well he was already
black and didn't want to give Bill
O'Reilly a heart attack so we waited and
then made up some [ __ ] about evolving
isn't it time to do that with pot come
on man you've gone down the list
reversing the stupidities of the past
healthcare torture gay marriage
immigration Cuba it spots turn
and not just legalization Obama should
acknowledge that putting people in jail
for nonviolent drug offenses was a giant
mistake in the first place and then he
should use the power of the presidential
pardon and free them all come on
come on you know you want to you've been
stingy with those pardons here's a great
way to make up for it and there's plenty
of precedent Lincoln a Republican
pardoned the southern rebels after the
Civil War Ford a Republican pardoned
Vietnam draft dodgers Ronald Reagan
signed an amnesty for 2.7 million
Mexican illegals
if Republicans can forgive people for
armed insurrection desertion and
speaking Spanish a Democrat can forgive
us for getting high thank you very much